There's something really in me,
who likes to take this risk.
And often, sometimes I think,
why the f*** did I do that?
I'm going to teach you
many different recipes,
presentations, how to really
make something happen.
I had a stepfather,
he was not a nice guy.
I always wanted to leave.
I was 14 years old
and I found a job.
I said, "it's perfect,
I can leave the house."
You're going to learn how
to be a better cook at home.
Teach your palate
little step by step.
You can toast your peppercorns
in the oven to release the oil.
Keep the pan.
Don't rinse the pan.
This is where we're
going to make our sauce.
I was the chef at a
French restaurant.
A manager comes to me and
says, "here is the new menu."
"What do you mean the new menu?"
"You didn't even talk to me."
I got so pissed off at him,
I took off my apron and said,
"well then you f***ing
cook the menu."
I said, you know, I want to be
in charge of my own destiny.
Instead of using parsley, I'm
going to use the carrot tops.
Most people would
just throw it away.
Don't use the
expensive olive oil
because it's a waste of money.
If you want to start your day
with a Bloody Mary like that,
you don't going to stop.
If you have passion
for what you do,
you're going to be
successful at the end.
They're going to say,
"where did you learn that?"
Did you learn it at
the MasterClass,
or did you go to
Paris for a year?
I'm Wolfgang Puck, and
this is my MasterClass.